pour commencer donc l'épidémie de grippe
aviaire car le phénomène a brusquement
changé de dimension aujourd'hui avec
cette déclaration de l' oms
l'organisation mondiale de la santé la
maladie a le potentiel pour tuer des
millions de gens parce qu'elle pourrait
se combiner au virus de la grippe
réalisme ou alarmisme en tout cas c'est
le branle bas de combat dans les
organisations internationales
on compte je vous le rappelle les huit
morts déjà et 10 pays touchés florence
magique dans cet élevage en thaïlande
sommeil une bombe à retardement
le virus qui a contaminé ses volailles
est particulièrement virulent des
millions de poulets sont éliminés
partout en asie
les paysans les enterre à la va vite où
les jettent parfois vivant dans les
rivières
de quoi inquiéter les experts qui
redoute la transmission massive et
rapide du virus chez l'homme avec des
millions de morts en perspective
le virus peut causer d'énormes dégâts
dans un organisme affaibli si le virus
de la grippe aviaire et le virus de la
grippe humaine se mélangent dans le
corps d'une même personne qu'est alors
il existe un risque considérable que le
fruit de ce mélange souhaiterait
infections c'est cette forme de virus
mutant qui a causé la mort aujourd'hui
de ce garçonnet de 6 ans en thaïlande
aujourd'hui dix pays asiatiques sont
touchés par la grippe du poulet
ce n'est pas en ingérant viande et oeufs
cuits que l'homme contracte ce virus
mais en respirons des poussières
contaminées par les plumes ou les
fientes de poulet
le virus peut aussi faire des ravages
chez le porc dont il est recommandé dans
un foyer d'infection animal portant sur
des oiseaux d'abattre également les
ports pour supprimer ce risque il y a
urgence à stopper net cette épidémie
aucun vaccin est actuellement disponible
la deuxième journée de l'est